i just want to clarify to everybody you
know you know i'm a big star trek fan
you don't got to be a star trek fan to
understand this in the 90s we had new
star trek shows
they were wildly popular star trek the
next generation was one of the most
popular shows of all time it was
syndicated on three networks that's huge
after that they said what do we do now i
don't know do a prequel now a lot of
people do like enterprise but it's a
prequel we're just like go back in time
i thought it was boring and take
existing stories where are we now
discovery cbs a prequel stacey abrams is
the president
they're accused of ripping off the story
here's the best part they start picard
which is
finally the 90s star trek gets a sequel
series and what is it about
the first season is basically member
berries remember riker remember picard
remember data and it's like okay yeah
i'm a big fan of all those things it's
fun to see them again what's season two
about they go back in time they're like
remember because something you know
happened in 2024 to turn earth into a
human supremacist planet and the
fascists must be stopped and i'm like
why is star trek at the same time that i
live no i want to watch nice [ __ ] well
also exactly the thing even if
spaceships
well this is what's so important
even if you're trying to cram your world
view into something where it otherwise
doesn't belong try to come up with some
clever analogy for it instead of going
human surprise we're going to talk about
human supremacy do you guys get it
watching at home do you get it do you
get what we're actually talking about
it's so obnoxious are people gay on the
new star trek
what are there any gay people well in
the in the reboot movies
they made sulu gay like they they did a
scene that didn't need to be in the
movie that was this this is one of the
issues i think takei was actually not
cool with that even though he's gay
right he said make new characters yeah
so in the in the movies they did a scene
where it's like they're coming to port
or whatever and then sulu runs up to a
guy who's got like a daughter and they
kiss and it's just like that did nothing
for the movie i don't care if the
characters are gay john constantine do
you guys know john constantina's dc dc
character he's they did a movie with
keanu reeves it wasn't really true to
the original character he's an amazing
character this character has been bi
since 1992 so he like he has boyfriends
and girlfriends and they make and it's
like a part of his character arc so when
i see a show i'm watching dc's legends
of tomorrow and he's got like a
boyfriend i'm not like why i'm like oh i
get his motivation is that his his
boyfriend's soul was trapped in hell i'm
like yeah i understand that i have no
issue with that that's fine it's when
they take characters and they put things
in plots that don't make sense for the
sake of just virtue singing to their
audience like look what we did
i feel like chris ruffo found something
that like with a disney one of the
disney directors saying that they're
trying to make like 50 of the characters
lgbt that wasn't just the director
saying that they have that i think on
their on their like mission i think they
have that written down that by 2050 it
would be
um and that's just not a very
interesting way to do it it's not it
doesn't make for good stories to say i'm
going to have this character with this
specific characteristics when you're
writing characters you have to like
listen to your characters you have to
invent them they have to be authentic
and real and you can't just like apply
stuff to your characters and say you
know here's my character mary and she's
going to be all of these things and i'm
just going to make that work and shove
them into that character it has to be
real i'll tell you why i think woke
plot writing doesn't work you have to
understand the motivations to feel for
the story and my the example i'll give
you is when the batman animated series
won i think the it was the first emmy i
could be wrong for an animated series
and it was with their episode in the
origins of mr freeze do you guys know
this story
comic book villains used to be
one-dimensional i'm going to take over
the world
and then in the batman animated series
they write the story about a scientist
whose wife is dying of a terminal
disease so he cryogenically freezes her
and then starts misappropriating
corporate funds from his job to try and
find a cure when the boss finds out he
says you're stealing my money shut it
down he's like no you'll kill nora you
can't so they get into a fight with the
security guards the cryo chemicals spray
all over them he becomes mr freeze his
entire motivations that his wife is
dying and he will stop at nothing to
save her life and so it's kind of sad
but he's a bad dude because he hurts
people and then it ends with him in his
prison cell like saying like oh nora and
he's holding a snow globe and it's like
miserably sad this guy became a villain
that's like wow those motivations man
when you see these woke stories like the
craft where they put a spell on a guy to
turn him gay i'm like
what is your motivation here yeah why do
it let's make a joke gay and i'm like i
don't understand what that has to do
with like your motivations in life are
you just mean people like that's lgbtq
representation tim they're trying to
tell us that that's where gay people
come from there's what they're trying to
say
in legends of tomorrow john constantine
he's this uh he's like a
exorcist he has a boyfriend his
boyfriend's soul gets damned to hell and
this
makes him distraught i'm like i
understand that motivation i don't you
know have attraction dudes but i can
understand caring about someone i
understand that motivation a lot of
these woke shows are motivated by
weird things like when um
brie larson and captain marvel steals
the clothing of the guy in the
motorcycle i'm like what was the purpose
of that plot point was it to show us
that she like brie is just a bad person
and that feminists are mean
like i don't like why why in the store
is like she's gonna steal a guy's
clothes and steal his motorcycle from
him and i i've said this before a number
of times but it's really important
whenever you're making anything and this
holds true for what we're doing with
freedom tunes as well even though we're
talking about politics when i'm making
something i'm not thinking what point
can i get across what's the agenda here
that's very rarely the case it's usually
just looking at a situation and saying
what do i think is funny and obviously
because i am a conservative person the
things that i'm going to think are funny
are probably things other conservative
people are going to think is funny when
they look at the issue or are funny when
they look at the issue if you go into it
going i desperately need the audience to
know every single piece of my political
world view related to this issue you're
just going to make garbage it's going to
be really really boring it's someone
someone super chatted us and we'll go
back in the super chat section and read
through it but i do want to point out a
bit of what your point was and this is
from um
i can't trust an alarm or whatever but
he was saying that uh before the empire
before the dark days and this was an uh
another
uh who tweeted this um i'm sorry not
tweeted who posted it they eddie he was
saying before the empire before the dark
days all of these social media platforms
were conservative and that's
mostly true remember remember when um
phil um phil defranco he hosted gary
johnson on his show libertarian
mike.com which went woke originally was
all about libertarianism and ron paul
interesting twitter was i don't remember
that donald trump and conservatives and
it was dominated the twitter was a lot
of journalists who are you know talking
and a lot of news organizations getting
no traction
and then conservatives were generating
massive attention and engagement now all
these platforms were taken over by the
far left kicked out all the people on
the right and they become stagnant dry
boring and broken well because they're
only interested in their ideological
perspective they're not interested in
new ideas they're interested in
entrenching and enforcing
the existing ones it's so troubling that
all these companies have become
ideological in one direction or another
because then it also leads other
companies to also want to become
ideological so now we have disney trying
to inject whatever liberal values but
then we have the daily wire who you know
is a news a news company right they hire
journalists they make news podcasts but
they're also getting in the kids
entertainment business i'm not sure if
they're going to inject any values in
their content but it just sucks that
every company now has developed a
political angle one way or another
because i don't know if that's what the
market has to bear we force it on to
these companies well with the the daily
wire realized that
as andrew breitbart said politics is
downstream from culture and for too long
conservatives have neglected to be
producing any kind of cultural content
typically conservatives just complain
about stuff and then they're content to
complain about it as it's like imagine
being in the titanic and complaining
that it's sinking and then not doing
anything to like save yourself save
others or stop the sinking from
happening
and that's what it was for a very very
long time the daily wire is like let's
start baling water or at least build a
life raft so
their content probably will have values
in it but it's going to be values we
recognize and probably like well and the
values should come into the work in an
organic fashion exactly as well i mean
that's what it should be like i remember
this was years ago now but i was
commissioned to write a play for the
williamstown theatre festival and um
i was working with a director who was
older and she was single and she was
trying to decide if she should have a
child
even though she didn't have a partner
and so we were talking about this and i
was like okay well we you know this is
what she wanted to do a play about i was
like okay cool so we started digging
into it and very very organically
the take of the play started to be
uh no
you probably shouldn't
have a child without you know a family
structure without not intentionally you
probably should not intentionally create
a fatherless child um
you know on purpose just to satisfy your
own
pleasure at this point and that was a
very organic perspective and uh it ended
up not getting produced and getting me
into a lot of trouble and i didn't stay
at the festival very long yeah but it
wasn't or it wasn't i didn't go into it
saying i want to write a play about the
integrity of the family unit that's just
sort of what happened was i wrote a play
that was about taking responsibility for
your reproductive material you know yeah
no absolutely and i would agree with you
this stuff has to come about organically
all entertainment is going to have
values in it people just can't escape
this and it's part of the reason why
storytelling has been so central to
human culture and civilization because
we get our moral values from the stories
that we tell each other stories that
we're told as children that we pass on
to our children and so the idea that
they're going to be value neutral is
incoherent it's basically an impossible
point for the there's no point to a
value neutral storiness
how would it exist and it's exactly it's
not even possible the question is
are these perspectives developing
organically because someone's trying to
tell a story and their worldview is
inevitably going to work itself into it
or is this a piece of propaganda which
exists explicitly to get me to accept
something i might not otherwise accept
that's something interesting too that i
think a lot about um like bible stories
right so you have a lot of you know
there's been a lot of critique about the
bible and like from a liberal world view
that this is you know anti everybody or
whatever but if you look at the bible
like
the stories are not telling you how
things should be necessarily in the old
testament yeah it's interesting they're
telling you how things are right these
are our ancestors expressing
their perspective on life and culture
and the world as they're living in it
and they're giving you that perspective
no it's an interesting combination
because there are obviously moments that
are instructive but it's not as if
because something is described in
scripture that it's being approved
exactly and that's so interesting
um you know and there's well we could go
on for about this for a while but
there's so many interesting stories
where you can see
you know the trajectory of something is
not what you thought like when joseph
gets sold into slavery in egypt
and it turns out that if joseph hadn't
been sold into slavery in egypt all of
the israelites would have starved to
death
yeah so what was the right thing to do i
don't know like that's fast exactly what
i want to mention this i don't take a
more liberal interpretation i i really
do believe in the bible but at the same
time i find it fascinating that
basically every religious text that i'm
familiar with
is narrative in some sense it's not just
a list of things that you should and
shouldn't do there's some of that right
when you look at a catechism for example
that lays out the rules but it's so
clear that humans understand through
story in the strongest possible way well
that's the greatest everything here's
something interesting the uh uh old
stories
i read this so you guys will have to
tell me if it's if it's uh correct or
not but i was reading this opinion piece
about heroes of the olden days like um
hercules and these these these ancient
heroes who would challenge the gods
fight against them or the titans
today our heroes are all a part of the
establishment and the authority
supermen and batman well as much as
they're sometimes at odds like batman is
a vigilante they still call upon him and
he still upholds the status quo superman
does the same thing i think a lot of
comics have done a great job exploring
these ideas in in real ways that were
thought provoking
challenging certain um you know rigid
moral standards we had captain america
he's basically propaganda in world war
ii
then you have this arc where he he he
becomes nomad he's like i can't stand
for this or you have civil war where
captain america is like i will not stand
for the government forcing people to
register you know and and then you have
the industrialist tony stark who's like
do what the government wants the
corporation working with government
these ideas were really uh interesting
and it made these comics from one
dimensional to multi-dimensional
challenging our own world view but in
positive ways now instead of being like
here's an interesting
here's an interesting character arc
captain america believes in freedom the
government wants you to register
how would he handle that now it's just
like you're all racist and you're all
bigots and bigots should be punished and
racist should be excised so the wokeness
and content is just becoming it's
reverting back to the one-dimensional
aspect of old comics that's just well
there was such an interesting thing that
happened and bizarre when barack obama
became president um and when he was
running which is all of the people who
had said up to that point question
authority started saying trust the
government the president is your friend
and it's like it was um
you know
people forgot that barack obama was just
a politician
you know just like all the other
politicians who's very similar to all of
the politicians who have ruled our
country yeah yeah but he had that
painting that said hope yeah sure right
yeah well shepherd fairy had the
painting he was supposed to end racism
though i feel like that was supposed to
be the deal with obama but now the
racism yeah that was but
now now people say that you know the
fact that we had a black president is
doesn't mean anything at all in terms of
the
progress away from being a racist
country exactly and they'll never say
these kinds of things which i find it
bizarre no exactly they'll never say
these kinds of things beforehand right
so when you're supposed to vote for
obama it's look this is going to be a
giant step towards ending racism of
course they didn't say well look if we
elect obama that is not at all going to
prove that this is a non-racist country
based on values and not skin colors
obama wasn't even extremely liberal as
as i understand i think he was um
against gay marriage when he announced
he was i guess
but hold on hold on
it was a very different time he was
pro-universal healthcare he campaigned
on that in
and eight she also voted against the
born alive act in like 2003 or 2002 as a
senator so he was very far to the left
on abortion and not a lot of economic
issues he was as well i think basically
no one in public life was in favor of
gay marriage if they had a political
career at that point yeah hillary
clinton i think in 2016 she wasn't even
in favor of gay marriage like leaked
emails came out or something thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you